freunde herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen video ich habe heute einen ganz
besonderen gast zu meiner seite die
gisela und sich leute schon immer mal
für eine obergrenze
aber mal vierfache vierfache oma opa
dann sind muss ich viermal gut kochen
und bloß sich bereit erklärt sich einen
tag von mir bekochen zu lassen und ein
paar wünsche geäußert dass darf gerne
leicht sein martin und ich probiere das
heute alles zu treffen zum frühstück
gibt es habe ich mir überlegt borat
verboten also privater angeröstet das
rote tomaten aus dem ofen relativ leicht
probieren wir es zu beschreiben und das
klingt gut so na dann du kannst ja
eigentlich ganz bequem machen sich wie
zu hause fühlen ich sollte für das
leibliche wohl und hoffe nicht schmeckt
sondern ein neuer muss alles gesagt wird
wir haben ja alle zutaten liegen ich
hoffe dass das brot genau nach meinem
vorstellung ist wie rüsten das ganze an
ich leite das so vielleicht ein bisschen
weniger als ein finger dick ist außen
kann sich nur knusprig werden und
vielleicht noch etwas flippiger der
aufzucht ist einfach ein bisschen
berater der tomaten kann ich eigentlich
dann direkt nächsten schritt fertig
machen so dann wahrscheinlich nicht
tomaten daran ein wenig olivenöl
zugeben wir jetzt einfach 15 minuten ich
mache schon mal die fahnen bestätigte
auch ein sehr einfach ist das nicht so
einfach guenstiger.de
jedem großstadt kaffee so oder so eben
nicht zu bekommen so lässt mir das ganze
jetzt mal an ganz wichtig ist dass man
das relativ häufig wendet dass es schön
gleichmäßig knusprig und goldbraun wird
und man kann das auch im backofen machen
genauso gleich also direkt kann man
beides machen aber wir wollten das
komplizierter macht so wie tomaten jetzt
raus wegen genau richtig aus die haut
ist so ein bisschen weich geworden dann
schnappen wir uns richtung mainz sind
brotscheibe daraufhin wir jetzt unsere
private also die auf 7 berater ist
einfach wunderschön wichtig ist nur dass
man es gut gerüstet weil sonst war ich
das halt direkt durch die tomaten
halbieren dadurch dass man diese dem
ofen anpackt macht was mit dem geschmack
so die fährt noch ein bisschen so ein
herzhafter also ich hab ich das gefühl
mit medien und jetzt parkplätze testung
auch aus dem grund etwas balsamico essig
das einfachste zwischenwasser bisher
vielleicht
probieren
[Musik]
da sind wir also vom frühstück wasser ja
also eigentlich schon abendlichen genau
beim frühstücks liegt bei dir sonst wie
auch nicht wirklich nicht jeden morgen
nicht gehen morgen will ich die unter
habe pampelmuse ohad nicht okay das ist
auch schon wieder sehr gesund aber man
muss sich ja auch mal gut gehen lassen
deshalb hoffe ich dass ich wenigstens
dann schmeckt das ist ein bisschen
zugeschaut und berater brot und quasi
einmal so die italienische keule zum
frühstück so dann wird er das werkzeug
was sagt das optische optisches brot
letztlich auch immerhin schneiden
sonst regiert das auch dem berater als
ich tatsächlich das erste mal schon sehr
cool dass ich noch was zum ersten mal
zeigt ein super dann weil ich zu viel
verraten so dass das sehr gerne auf
essen und dann sehen wir uns gleich
einen der teller hoffentlich mehr ist
zur bewertung ihrer danke alles leben
ist das ist auch schon mal gutes zeichen
es hat geschmeckt auch wenn kein
klassisches frühstück hat sehr gut
geschmeckt dann ist jetzt mal die große
frage ich bräuchte ein deckel auf eine
note 0 bis 10 persönliches empfinden gut
war das gericht einfach mit einer
kleinen einordnung der welt es schmeckt
gut
war vor allem das bewahrt man hat mehr
respekt im fresche 0 jugend ist es schon
so werde und sagen wir ja ich weiß jetzt
nicht wie anfangs spot mit äpfeln was
bitte sagen wir mal 48 bleibt ja da wird
nicht auf sehr darüber folgen haben
glaubt können wir uns einigen da haben
sie einen raum für verbesserung führt
nämlich jetzt beim mittagessen auch
selbstbewusster medien da wird es wieder
gleich wieder maritim und lass dich
überraschen dass das thema fürs
mittagessen es gibt ein salat und zwar
mit einem lachs streifen romaner
salatherzen auf so einem bunten salat da
ist feldsalat drin mangold drin kleine
tour mädchen also quasi das ganz leicht
ist nach dem frühstück schon ein
bisschen wichtiger war das abendessen
haben wir dann noch mal richtig platz
weil da gibt es was besonderes und fange
einfach mal an dem ich den lachs hier
zurechtschneiden einem präsentierteller
für mache ich den schnitt einfach mal so
extrem ist natürlich ganz normal mit an
die romane salatherzen habe ich schon
von den äußeren blättern befreit ich
schneide jetzt einmal vorsichtig und auf
was muss trotzdem noch weiter
zusammenhalten und dann habe ich hier
einfach
und so legen wir sie gleich auch den
grillgeräte romane sind auch das ist
ausgefallen ist die pin sind wir dann
gleich noch mal so schön so mit essig
honig öl also zu einer kleinen mission
mit dem dressing quasi was wir dann auch
den salat geben ich meine nur eine
charlotte dazu dich ganz fein schneiden
sowie kommst um dressing und ein
weiterer umstand her fehlt noch bei sami
qualität wir machen honig die chance
seinem boliden öl balsamico essig und
das dann einfach abschmecken also gerne
ein bisschen honig ein als allererstes
dann hüther schlug beisammen co essig
olivenöl ist er gleich auch zum grillen
benutzt werden und die chance wohl auch
ein bisschen mehr sind das müssen wir
jetzt demolieren hat er einfach kräftig
mixen
traum
leckerbissen am grill ich schnappe mir
hier schöne geräte salatherzen
findet das ganze einmal mit unserer
viele direkte sieht so richtig aus es
ist auch total richtig alter und wir
legen auf
sehen die einmal kurz an auch schön
heißt ja auch was den geruch der ectacom
lokalisieren honig ganz aromatisieren
wir ganz einfach nur mit kräutern wie
wir nebendran packen wichtig ist hier
wirklich dass die haut die ganze zeit
kontakt hat dass sie gleichmäßig
gebraten wird damit die richtig schön
knusprig wird haben wir das eben hier
auf dem kurs also gemacht
[Musik]
schauen sie mal die haut an sehr schöne
rollen die salatherzen sind fertig
gedreht den lachs ziehen wert gab wird
lecker
[Musik]
das mittagessen disparaten schön reichen
erstmal anschauen nein nicht zu schaden
das klingt doch gut also auf der haut
schön kross gebratenen vor allem
gespannt auf die salatherzen ich glaube
ja deshalb gehe ich auch zuerst planen
ich hatte so auch leute oder nein aber
schon die pomade salatherzen er was zu
entdecken aber
schmeckt ganz gut also dieser kontrast
zwischen den bitterstoffen würde ich mal
sagen wir welcome initiierten ist lecker
super gestanden
ok
dann bin ich vor allem gespannt was da
am ende für eine note drauf kommt aber
das wollen wir erst recht aufgegessen
ist das gleich ich bin stolz und
zufrieden der teller das wieder leer ja
ganz leer lehrer gespart erst an der
kappe nehmen diese kombination von
bitterstoffen und dem süßen dressing war
okay alles jetzt wie immer die große
frage wie gut hat es geschmeckt ja also
zehn hab ich nur sagen wir haben ja noch
was kommt
da ist da schließe ich mich anders kommt
noch was und das wird besonders jetzt
wahrscheinlich hier im hintergrund
pizzateig ist schon den ganzen tag
gegangen waren wir ein bisschen und dann
machen wir die plätze endlich wieder
pizza machen und nicht irgendeine pizza
sondern pizza bianca stadt tomatensoße
basiert das ganze auf rekord als auch
das allererste was ich machen werde ich
konnte eine schüssel geben dann werde
ich dazu wenig käsereien person auch
sehr leicht sehr leicht möglich in die
haben ja bisher für während sparflamme
gefahren eigentlich mehr oder weniger
gerade das mittagessen war ja doch eher
reduziert das heißt jetzt kann man ein
bisschen
den pizzateig habe ich da jetzt schon
fertig stehen das habe ich schon mal
gemacht dass verlinkt euch in der video
beschreibung bisschen wohnen abgebrannt
das ganze ein bisschen frischer zu
machen das rezept von thomas koch zu
allem
das lasse jetzt einfach so stehen
vermenge ich gleich die machen jetzt
hier vorne weiter und zwar machen wir
unsere beiden herdplatten an in die 1
geben wir zucker lassen den
karamellisieren ein bisschen einfacher
wenn man ein kleines stückchen wasser
schon dazu macht wichtig sei aber vor
allem dass man nicht unberührt werden
der kombiniert werden wir warten ab
deswegen schmolzen ist dann funktioniert
das am besten hier machen wir jetzt
schon fing aus drin hier machen wir bei
sanikis bibeln ich habe tatsächlich
selbst noch gar nicht so wahnsinnig oft
pizza bianca gegessen das einmal dass
sie gegessen habe und das wesentlich
würde vielleicht gar nicht so direkt
denken war tatsächlich in italien das
ist nichts neu modisches oder irgendwie
so eine verfremdung von pfizer sowie
pizza hawaii sondern das ist durch eine
traditionelle sache auch wenn der zucker
karamellisiert ist gehen wir in sozialen
dazu schön dünn geschnitten eric hat
endlich seinen willen bekommen wäre mich
gefilmt wie sie geschnitten wurde von
ihr kommt dazu und guter schluck
balsamico
wenn er verkauft es geht mir noch eine
wasserrechtliche wenn das ungefähr so
aussieht gehen wir noch mal einen
schluck wasser dazu wollen nämlich das
fiktive brauchen ist derzeit das
abendessen ich habe hier einen turm von
pizza tagen stehen sich allesamt
mühsamen vorbereitet habe ich jetzt ein
bisschen die arbeitsfläche mailen
wirklich ist immer so ein kleiner act
beziehungsweise braucht so viel planung
ich bin immer so ungeplant und einen tag
vorher diesen pizzateig machen dadurch
mache ich es relativ selten
beziehungsweise eigentlich viel zu
selten aber er ist richtig schön
aufgegangen die aufmerksame werden im
hintergrund gesehen haben die gehen wir
einmal raus und die normalerweise unter
wert schon richtig los der pizzateig
sodann einmal die oberfläche ein
bisschen wählen und dann formen wir
einen kleinen brand
danach nehmen der anderen seite noch mal
nach vorn dann brauchen wir ein wenig
von unserer ricotta mischung streichen
wir ein bisschen darauf lässt sich nicht
perfekt ist aber überhaupt kein problem
weil bei der re konnte auch ein bisschen
verläuft gleich im backofen muss man
eher so ein bisschen wie diese
mozzarella käse behandeln wir ein
bisschen rosmarin drauf ein paar von
unseren geräten camping welt von jazz
würdigt sehen würde was will ich hoffe
er wäre stolz
den mozzarella drüberziehen richtig dass
man davor ist denn trocknet weil wir
wollen nicht zu viel flüssigkeit darauf
sich schon gut aussuchen sagen ja aber
es ist schon befremdlich finde ich auch
so eine pizza zu sehen und keine
tomatensoße darauf ist schon was eigenes
und in einer
direkt runter mit der flamme
da ist das ding cluster aus pizza bianca
lieben und über
hast du das schon mal gesehen nein damit
die nicht gerne ja das sieht hübsch aus
muss sie muss sich verbeugen die nach
politische witze sie tut es
die zwiebeln sind sehr nah oder so
interessant wie der business ist pizza
das ist schon auch wieder recht sparsam
mit dem seite oder
[Musik]
wird es zeit dass wir nicht nur die
sondern noch drei weitere petzen
verputzen
diese sehr schön vereinigen so locker
hin drin nicht so viel mit am tisch so
das war's dann wohl jetzt ja spaß
gemacht das ist auch richtig so das
freut mich das letzte war eigentlich das
interessanteste ist auch nicht von daher
ja das kann man jetzt noch musst du
sagen also wie gut hat es dir geschmeckt
ist die geschmackskombinationen was
sagst du zu den süßen zwiebel die waren
toll vor einigen mit dem roman von ein
bisschen war also eine besondere
präsentation aber so ganz weiß jetzt was
hat schon wird was würdest du dieser
pizza geben
[Musik]
ob die gemeinde
die steige
dann müsste ich bin dann bin ich auch
zufrieden ich finde das finde ich sehr
lecker es ist für mich etwas sehr
sommerlich ist das im sommer wird dieser
rucola der kleine der zitronen abrieb im
recorder auch sehr sehr lecker richter
sowie
groß marine online findet ihr auch mal
eben schöner kann man jetzt auch noch
trinken werden zum ausbacken vielen dank
dass du dabei warst gerade ganz viel
spaß gemacht und was auch nette
gesellschaft ja dann hoffe ich dass
solche auch spaß gemacht hat wir sehen
uns beim nächsten video wieder und dann
instagram ist verlinkt